smart shopping well earlier this morning
we heard from unlv's dean of medicine dr
mark khan yeah he discussed kind of
where we stand here in southern nevada
as we fight the pandemic we also asked
him your questions
it's interesting i think a lot of folks
when we talk about vaccine hesitancy
they don't trust how fast the vaccine
was created how fast it's been approved
by the fda and so forth and how fast the
public has been
receiving it pregnant women for example
how do you
respond to those who have either those
hesitancies over the vaccine or just
don't trust it at all
so so look you know the technology
behind the mrna vaccines really goes
back to about 1985.
we have had other mrna vaccines for
things like ebola etc that haven't been
fda approved because we don't have ebola
in this country
so this was really a derivation of an
existing technology and you know the
proof's in the pudding with billions of
doses of vaccine given now this is a
safe and effective vaccine
is are we at a point now where
it's almost like the flu where it's not
a matter of beating the coronavirus
pandemic but we just sort of learned to
live with a version of covid19
so you know i hope that if we get enough
people vaccinated we're going to see a
lot less of this disease
coronaviruses naturally circulate
through the population so i think we're
going to be living with
with a form of the cova virus i think we
just all hope that it's not as lethal
and not as deadly
let's get to some of your questions we
have some questions we'd asked the
public to to submit their questions for
you as we knew we were going to be on
here's a question from stu who says he
got the single dose j j vaccine back in
april trying to find out whether or not
the pfizer or modern vaccine gives
higher immune response for a booster you
can really mix and match there is some
data that suggests that if you got the
pfizer vaccine and you boost with
moderna there may be a more robust
immune response so it's certainly not
wrong to do that but i don't think we
have the data really comparing
head-to-head to say one way is better
than another what is known is people
who've been vaccinated need to get a
booster shot final question i believe
comes from dj who talks about why
asks why masks are mandatory indoors
everywhere except for restaurants a
place where we're all constantly opening
our mouths leaving saliva on the rims of
glasses utensils
she knows they need to make money too
just curious i think that goes back to
the idea that we were talking about
before of
some of the regulations that are still
in place
is there a is it a bit um
confusing i think for some members of
the public to see
what's allowed what's not allowed
i don't know how to respond to that but
it there's some sort of confusion i
think some among some of the public
there's science and there's public
perception
um the science would suggest that we
should be wearing mass as much as
possible but then there's a practical
reality you can't eat and drink through
a mask right so when you're in a
restaurant you know you still have to
lift the mass to eat and drink
the amount of time that you keep the
mask on though is is really going to
determine how good the protection
actually is when you're outside because
you're not in an enclosed space
there is more area for
particles to dissipate if you will so
you're not going to get as high a
concentration and that's why
mass don't have to be worn outdoors and
one of the interesting things is you
know we had a very very light flu season
last year and that's because of social
distancing so in fact it works
well dr khan good to see you once again
good to see you in person and have a
happy thanksgiving happy thanksgiving
john thank you for your time appreciate
it folks get
vaccinated hi still me you can watch the
full 10-minute interview with dr khan on
8newsnow.com as i mentioned we had a
lengthy discussion talking about a lot
of different aspects of the coronavirus
as you can catch that online if you're
interested and thank you to everybody
who submitted questions that was
important for us too